[Musica]
affetto da sviluppata tra set i conti il
patatrac patatrac patatrac
salve perché ci sono io sotto forma di
fantasma perché non hai mai attori da
poter utilizzare giusto
sai perché sono qui oggi perché lo
sketch l'ho scritto io anche ma
soprattutto perché voglio farti
spaventare per davvero come voglio farti
provare in vero terrore voglio
contorcersi le budella e farti provare
il sapore della morte potresti farlo
dopo perché volevo parlare di piccoli
brividi e si cose con registrati non
vorrei che mi interrompe si trova su
perché avevo montare da un pò un casino
se devo tagliare le tue parti poi
migliaia
se potessi farlo sguardo seri passi tra
massimo 10 minuti io ho finito ci conto
e mi raccomando grazie mille e vi
raccomando però uno scappare
[Musica]
e dopo due anni sono qui di nuovo
parlare di piccoli brividi
la serie che ha segnato tutti i
ragazzini degli anni bla bla bla bla bla
chissenefrega andatevi a rivedere il
video di due anni fa se volete qualche
informazione in più oggi per questo
halloween ormai passato voglio parlarvi
di uno dei primissimi episodi che ho
visto di questa serie ed è sicuramente
quello che mi è rimasto più impresso
nella memoria al mostro al mostro e non
solo cielo in dvd ma questo episodio si
può trovare anche su netflix anche se
credo sia completamente sbagliata la
serie che celi e questo episodio al
mostro al mostro viene considerato il
primo episodio della prima stagione
quando sono abbastanza sicuro che non
sia così quindi non ve lo so dire ma
poco importa per questo video questo è
l'episodio di piccoli brividi al mostro
al mostro l'episodio inizia con lucy la
nostra protagonista che si diletta a
spaventare il suo fratellino ho mai
sentito parlare del mangiatore di piedi
peppe fetish
[Musica]
o no la scena finisce a metà dopo soli
due minuti di puntata che so quale
mostro incredibile avrà attaccato a
stavano scherzando se ero quasi cascato
con quel taglio di montaggio ma chi ci
casca e proprio il fratellino che corre
urlando dai genitori non si vuole
smetterla di spaventare tuo fratello che
serve avere un fratellino se non lo si
può tortura basta hai capito che bella
frase da dire in famiglia e di minuti
cosa pensi degli immigrati che ci rubano
il lavoro e dei neri che si siedono nei
posti davanti sul pullman ma la nostra
figlia del demonio a un impegno deve
restituire un libro in biblioteca che
non le è piaciuto
cosa avrei preferito un cavallo con due
teste e con dei denti mostruosi madonna
signorina è che si faccia curare il
bibliotecario le consiglia di cercarne
un altro
ciao lucy e cosa hai preso frankestein
bella luci non vorrei essere io a dirlo
ma il tuo amico e ecco è come dire alla
camicia di merda frankenstein è un
classico lo sai vero sì ma perlomeno un
mostro c'è sarebbe bello se esistessero
sul serio certo che esistono ne hai uno
al tuo fianco o no dai poverina ci sto
andando pesantissimo alla fine non è poi
così male
serve avere un fratellino se non lo si
può tortura basta appunto questo impegni
trunk i piccoli occhi
e poi alle mani su dati c quando mi ha
ridato il libro era così uscito che
quasi mi sfuggiva ma che schifo ma prima
di tornare a casa
lucy si accorge di essersi dimenticate i
pattini che non le abbiamo mai visto
indossare e torna a prenderli scoprendo
però una verità sconcertante musica
classica i vecchi di merda a cui
piacciono cose vecchie
a cosa serve se non li con torturare
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] alla faccia dei piccoli
primi ma che schifo a quanto pare il
bibliotecario alla passione per i ragni
a cui dà da mangiare altri piccoli
insetti
va beh a me sta roba fa veramente schifo
ma non è poi così tanto grave sai cosa
non ho più 12 anni
se vuoi veramente farmi spaventare devi
impegnarti di più ma l'uomo non solo a
una dieta ricca di fibre ma anche una
bella sorpresa
[Musica]
ok posso accettare la maschera da
ammiraglio akbar
ma quel verso scusa come che avevi detto
prima
sarebbe bello se esistessero sul serio
ma certo immaginati un mondo popolato da
ste creature simili a delle cernie
giganti che fanno in mezzo alla strada
in compenso sarebbe un'ottima puntata di
black mirror lucy giustamente scappa e
lo va a riferire i genitori che mi piace
non si usa più salutare visto nostra
biblioteca
sì lo ammetto quel dialogo quando l'ho
sentito la prima volta sono scoppiato a
ridere per mezz'ora e qui inizia una
delle cose più anni 90 che abbiano mai
fatto il momento perché non mi credete
che c'era in ogni singolo film e serie
tv in quel periodo il non riuscire a
farti credere dai tuoi genitori dopo
aver visto fantasmi mostri alieni vari
animali parlanti o giocattoli che
prendono vita ogni singola scena
potrebbe essere riassunta in mamma papà
ho visto un inserire elemento
paranormale non ti chiediamo dove lo
giuro non ti crediamo era così fino a un
minuto fa non ti crediamo non ti
crediamo
gli anni novanta signore signori larry
lei fate troppo grosse forse ma mi
piacciono così o no grazie larry grazie
per aver condiviso con noi questa tua
passione larry siccome neanche il suo
amico le crede decide di tornare dal
bibliotecario armata di macchina
fotografica
presto mi crederai fa finta di uscire
per farlo trasformare molto furba e
passa all'attacco ma ovviamente si
dimentica del flash
scappa pure piccolina io adoro mangiare
di corsa e io che pensavo di avere la
lista dei miei comici preferiti già
finita qui ci vanno lui sì che è doug
stanhope il bibliotecario di piccoli
brividi terzo posto deciso a posto lui
si riesce a scappare di nuovo ma il
mostro la rintraccia buonasera lusi mi
faresti entrare un attimo
devo dire che l'attore riesce a dare
un'aria da stalker barra pedofilo barra
mostro delle paludi decisamente
convincente
[Musica]
spero di rivederti molto presto
sarà la musica sarà la regia ma funziona
aspettate la riassumo io ho visto cose
non ti crediamo e lo giuro non ti
crediamo quindi decide di far sviluppare
il rullino vi ricordate no gli anni
novanta sviluppare i rullini delle
macchine fotografiche no vabbè ma lo
stalker la raggiunge bignè e sei sempre
convinta che esistano i mostri signor
mamme
grazie infinite per aver riportato allo
zaino al lusso magari questa è la volta
buona che i 100 ricrederanno lusi a
proposito ne andrebbe di venire a cena
domani sera non si è parlato tanto e ci
piacerebbe conoscerla meglio
o forse no complimenti e nella casa più
buia del mondo si preparano a mangiare e
qui arriva un classico di piccoli
brividi il colpaccio di scena finale in
ogni libro in ogni puntata non facevo
altro che aspettare sto pistone che
avrebbe cambiato l'intera storia roba
che shyamalan e un principiante
e qui si scopre che cosa c'è per cena
ecco lo avrebbe dovuto essere una
sorpresa visto che ce l'ha chiesto
c'è lei ha capito bene
[Musica]
anche loro sono dei mostri più super
twist
che in realtà non ha il minimo senso se
loro erano dei mostri fin dall'inizio
perché non hanno creduto subito al usi o
magari invece di fare finta di niente
perché non parlarne in modo diverso
nessuno deve conoscere la nostra vera e
di chi se anche lui si è un mostro
perché era spaventata dalla presenza di
un altro mostro non dovrebbe essere una
cosa normale per loro ma chi se ne frega
anche perché c'è un altro colpo di scena
dalla finestra si vede un terzo mostro
avvicinarsi pian piano era il ragazzino
di colore con una maschera brums o part
two che pure questo non ci ha molto
senso perché mai il ragazzino stava
girando con una maschera perché stava
sbirciando dalla finestra voleva fare
una rapina
non lo sapremo mai l'unica cosa che so è
questo episodio mi fa impazzire piccoli
brividi sta invecchiando male sia a
livello di effetti sia a livello di
sceneggiatura ma una cosa che non è mai
cambiata e l'atmosfera ogni puntata
riesce a trasportati dentro un mondo
dove tutto è possibile
tenendoti incollato allo schermo
dall'inizio alla fine e tra l'altro
questa storia del twist ending mi ha
segnato profondamente ha fatto crescere
dentro di me questa malsana passione per
i colpi di scena anche i più brutti
anche quelli che hanno poi rovinato un
film o una serie tv ed è per questo che
voglio mettere un piccolo extra in
questo episodio vorrei elencarvi i tre
colpi di scena di cui ho memoria tratti
dai libri di piccoli brividi
dunque il primo sicuramente l'avventura
del mostruoso blog c'è un ragazzino
aspirante scrittore che un giorno trova
una macchina da scrivere e scopre che
questa particolare macchina arrendere
alle tutto ciò che lui scrive ma se ne
accorge troppo tardi intanto lui ha già
iniziato a scrivere una storia di un
enorme blob rosa che distrugge la città
e si mangia le persone il colpo di scena
qui è che tutto quello che tu hai letto
fino alla fine del libro in realtà era
una storia scritta dal blu è la scena
finale sono due blog che commentano
questa cosa la ogni tanto la mattina mi
sveglio con ancora pezzi di cervello che
micolano dalle orecchie per questo
storia qui un'altra storia con un finale
vagamente simili
e c'è qualcuno nel buio questa storia
racconta di un ragazzino che riceve la
telefonata da un altro ragazzino che è
bloccato nel suo seminterrato per un po
parlano via telefono ma poi quando si
incontrano il protagonista scopre che
questo ragazzino che l'ha chiamato al
telefono
in realtà è un mostro alieno tutto
sbudellò zoe il colpo di scena di questa
storia qui è che tutto quello che hai
letto era un sogno ma non nel
protagonista dell'alieno cosa perché e
dulcis in fundo il campeggio degli
orrori e questa storia è fuori di testa
allora mandano un gruppo di ragazzini
tra cui nostro protagonista in un
campeggio ovviamente essendo un piccoli
brividi il gruppo di ragazzi pensa di
divertirsi invece succedono le peggio
cose eventi paranormali gente che
sparisce eccetera eccetera il colpo di
scena in questa storia qua e tenetevi
forte e che i genitori dei ragazzi li
hanno mandati lì per superare una prova
li hanno praticamente mandati non ad un
campo estivo ma ad un campo di
addestramento del governo segreto perché
per prepararli alla loro prossima
missione invadere la terra
perché loro erano degli alieni che
stavano addestrando i propri figli per
invaderci porca [ __ ] complimenti ha
tra l'altro io vorrei dire una cosa a
netflix netflix io ti adoro tra l'altro
avevo detto video fa che non saresti mai
arrivato in italia poi ne parliamo in un
altro video però vorrei farti giusto un
appunto potresti modificare se non
addirittura a rimuovere le immagini di
anteprima delle cose che sto per
guardare no perché non so se te ne sei
accorta spolverano come dei cani per
esempio non questa puntata di piccoli
brividi a come immagini di anteprima il
twist finale i genitori trasformati ora
per st serie chi se ne frega il problema
è che succede con tutte le altre serie
che guardo che tra l'altro riesce a
prendere in 40 50 minuti di puntata
proprio l'unico frank e spoiler
comunque a parte questa cosa qui grazie
mille per aver seguito questo video
adoro riprendere ogni tanto in mano una
puntata di piccoli brividi perché
proprio fa parte della mia vita ed è
entrato dentro di me grazie a questa
storia dei colpi di scena
grazie ancora
e ci vediamo al prossimo video
allora come siamo ansiosi di morire
dentro temi cosa cazzo vuoi io non solo
qualsiasi fantasma che ciccia fuori da
dietro la porta a farti 2 a spaventarsi
per quella frazione di secondo
io sono una parte della tua memoria io
sono la stessa persona in cui ti sei
trasformato l'anno scorso i ricordi
quando hai scoperto le liste degli
influencer e adesso che sai chi sono e
abbiamo finito di scherzare
guarda questo video ciao ragazzi si sono
vedevano come ben sapete sono una
ragazza a cui piacciono le sfide etiche
e per questa ragione che cazzo è poco
che cos'è e la fine di tutti e un video
in cui c'è quelle che sponsorizza
corrosioni con in mezzo anche degli
youtuber che hanno vinto un torneo
e aggiunge simpatico e miss alpe
l'annuncio del vincitore e della
prossima sfida grandissimi e ora che ti
ho fatto vedere il peggio il fondo del
barile
sei abbastanza spaventato merda
[Musica]
solo
no